all right let's now go to some stunning
new polling data which reveals that
there could be a brutal 2024 election
cycle coming for republicans and it is
all revealed thanks to a Fox News poll
now I want to remind people
there's no hypocrisy in saying Fox News
content is agit trash that should be
flushed down the toilet but we can look
at their polling Fox News polling is
fine it's relatively well rated and it's
it's generally pretty well done you know
Fox doesn't do the polling itself just
like CNN doesn't do its own they hire a
polling firm okay check this out and
this could really be a preview of what's
coming uh Fox poll shows Republicans in
for a brutal 2024 election even Fox is
admitting on air
that the policies it pushes aren't all
that popular with voters
they put up a poll and good for them for
doing it showing how popular certain
proposals to try to mitigate gun
violence are with the American people
and these are not shocking numbers to my
audience because we've been looking at
similar polling data for more than a
decade since the Sandy Hook shooting in
Connecticut background checks for guns
87 percent of Americans favor that and
again that means in all cases even
interpersonal sales all transactions
must have a background check enforce
existing gun laws 81 percent you've got
to be 21 to buy all guns that's not the
law in a lot of places right now 81
percent ban assault weapons 80 percent
favor that
and only 45 percent believe that more
citizens should be carrying guns this is
yet another issue on which the
right-wing media narrative has lost the
average American now obviously you go to
rural Northern Indiana where I've spent
some time and you ask people about these
things very few people will want
background checks for guns and they'll
mostly be against abortion now that's
the other question that this poll looked
at abortion should be 56 percent say
legal and 43 say illegal now when you
ask the question this way this is the
split 56-43
if you actually delve further into this
and you explain to people 99 of
abortions happen before I think it's 21
weeks and you explain more about the
reality of abortion you actually get
even more support for abortion just
should just flat out be legal before 21
weeks and yet there are states that have
passed abortion bans far earlier than
that so there's a few different things
here that I think are important to
consider this isn't really newsworthy in
the sense that on policy Republicans
have been losing for a long time in 2016
Trump eked out Hillary and it came down
to under a hundred thousand votes in
three states but then as the country
continued to move more to the left
it actually hurt Republicans in
elections the 2018 midterms were not
great for republicans in 2020 they lost
even more including the White House in
2022 it was going to be a red wave and
yet the Democratic majority in the
Senate actually grew it's interesting to
have a red wave where Democrats gain
seats in the Senate although they did
lose the house and this all may be
culminating in 2024. now I'm going to be
doing some interesting podcast
appearances coming up and one of the
things that I hope comes up is what's at
stake in 2024 because we have another
third of the Senate up for re-election
as we do every two years that's always
the case we have a presidential election
which may well be a rematch between Joe
Biden and Donald Trump and we will have
what I believe will be an inflection
point a fork in the road whatever
metaphor you want to use when it comes
to mega trumpism mega trumpism has hurt
Republicans dramatically but it has hung
on thanks to the likes of Lauren bobert
Marjorie Taylor green and some others
maintaining their seats in the House and
uh elements of this in the Senate
lunatics like Josh Hawley and Ted Cruz
even though Trump insulted Cruz's wife
Cruz has become a big Trump isn't
trumpism acolyte Etc
Republicans will decide in 2024 are we
sticking with this direction
and potentially losing
or are we actually going to go in a
different direction altogether so a ton
is up for grabs in 2024. the Republican
Party
has made politics more important for
young people with the issue of abortion
this was the problem we always knew
would happen if Roe v Wade were repealed
yes it would energize some people and
they will want and try to do even more
but at the same time you can no longer
raise money to try to overturn Roe v
Wade you have to deal with the
consequences of it being gone and the
Republican strategy has always been to
present themselves as an opposition to
some kind of evil something scary
abortion through Roe v Wade mattered
when Roe v Wade was a thing
you've got to keep the wedge issue to
keep voters scared so that they go out
and vote with you they won now that
issue has lots of its power now I know
that they've been saying well now we
need a federal ban on abortion it's fine
that Roe v Wade was overturned but now
we need to ban ban it outright federally
short-lived really unpopular idea it
also wouldn't pass because we've got a
Democratic Senate so now they're saying
well let's focus on trans anti-woke Etc
but the polling isn't looking great on
that either so increasingly they do need
to try to steal steal an election to win
one Trump tried it in 2020 and it didn't
work and we have to make sure it doesn't
work in 2024 either but a potential
bloodbath for Republicans coming up in
what is now just 18 months incredible
it's April which means Earth month is
here this is the time to consider the
products you buy and the impact they
have on our planet so if you're still
using conventional toilet paper in your
home there's no better time to switch to
Reels 100
bamboo toilet paper 30 million trees are
destroyed every year for toilet paper in
the U.S alone real paper makes toilet
paper from 100 bamboo stocks which grow
forever no cutting down trees so when
you use real it doesn't feel like you're
sacrificing anything to help the Earth
real paper is soft and fluffy the way
you're used to it's always shipped free
to my door in plastic free packaging I
can schedule it on a subscription if I
want and real is partnered with one tree
planted and with every box of real paper
you buy they fund reforestation efforts
across the country make a positive
change this Earth month go to
realpaper.com Pacman use code Pacman for
thirty percent off and free shipping the
link is down below